kids head back to classrooms in just
three weeks if you can believe that now
various charities businesses and
organizations are giving out free school
supplies to help families in need jeremy
j ford joins us for an event with
families and organizers
[Music]
i'm here at the cox back to school fair
in downtown summerlin where local
families are showing up to get free
school supplies and resources in
preparation for the new school year it
was definitely worth coming out to
see
what's going on in the community and to
talk to the clark county school district
dianna collins recently moved to las
vegas she came out today to get school
supplies and learn more about the school
district it's nice to have those extra
supplies and it means that we don't have
to buy nearly as much as we would have
to without
the offerings that are here so she's
getting a free backpack full of supplies
handed out by the clark county school
district police there's a lot of
families out there that have a lot of
questions they have a lot of unknowns
about what they need to do this allows
all these agencies together to get
together in one location and learn about
everything from transportation to school
safety and this year's immunizations so
there's a bunch of vaccines listed for
kindergarteners seventh graders have two
required shots and that new requirement
for 12th graders is one meningitis
vaccine which can be obtained at your
primary physician's office or a
qualified provider it's going to help
when i go back and look up their
particular websites so it brings
back awareness as the kids get ready to
go back to school jeremy j ford live
local now
if you missed today's event you can
catch another back to school drive next
saturday at the boulevard mall immunized
nevada will be on site to provide school
required shots